the number one place to get membership's during
the Joe Biden era, is, of course, join Pakman
Dotcom, grab a membership, get instant access
to the bonus, show the commercial free audio,
feed the commercial free video feed, all of
that great stuff.
Plus the feeling of knowing you are supporting
an alternative to homogenous corporate media.
Join Pakman.
Dotcom is the place to do it and what a day
to do it.
By the way, there are increasing discussions
as we transition from Donald Trump to Joe
Biden about the possibility of Joe Biden pardoning
Donald Trump.
And we have heard from folks on the right,
we've heard even from some folks on the left,
we've heard from national security figures
and others.
Maybe Joe Biden should do for the country
what Gerald Ford did for the country to Richard
Nixon, which is to pardon Nixon the way that
Joe Biden could pardon Donald Trump.
I think that this is a disastrous idea.
And under no circumstances whatsoever should
Joe Biden pardon Donald Trump.
First of all, merely on the facts, Trump has
been way worse than Nixon, much more weaponized,
much more dangerous to the United States in
terms of what the U.S. is supposed to be as
the democracy and everything else that we
believed up, at least until Donald Trump was
elected, the U.S. was supposed to be.
Secondly, the mere idea that you would be
able to unite with these absolutely delusional
Trump if Joe Biden were to pardon Donald Trump
is a complete and total fantasy.
And so when I hear anecdotally people across
the political spectrum to differing degrees
saying, well, I don't know, maybe Joe Biden
should look at pardoning Donald Trump, absolutely
not.
Let's look at some of the arguments.
One argument is, if Biden pardons Trump, it
prevents Trump from pardoning himself, which
would be terrible.
But the timing doesn't make any sense.
By the time Biden can do the pardoning, Trump
can no longer do it.
Maybe the idea was if Biden sends a signal
that he'll pardon Trump, then maybe Trump,
but doesn't make any sense.
It makes absolutely no sense whatsoever.
It wouldn't get a single Trump to cooperate
with the Biden administration.
It just will never happen.
And if you've been paying attention the last
four years, how could you possibly think that
there is anything Joe Biden could do that
would get a significant portion of Trump is
to cooperate with the Biden administration?
I heard former FBI Director James Comey, for
example, suggesting a pardon quote as part
of healing the country.
And getting us to a place where we can focus
on things that are going to matter over the
next four years, gimme a break, Jim.
The Trump wing of the Republican Party is
not going to heal.
They're not going to participate in any healing,
at least that's for sure.
If Joe Biden were to pardon Donald Trump,
it wouldn't make any difference.
It will become it actually may be worse.
It may become part of the conspiracy theories.
They will say, well, Biden was forced to do
it as part of a deal to protect Hunter or
some kind of harebrained thing.
It won't work.
It's it's nuts to think that it would be another
reason not to pardon Donald Trump is that
we need Trump and his family to be as busy
as possible dealing with civil lawsuits, investigations
and possible charges that will come to the
Trump organization, to the Trump campaign,
and maybe even to Trump and his family members
as well, because that may actually be.
What prevents Donald Trump from running again
in twenty twenty four, let's not give Trump
any escape from years of being stuck in a
legal hellhole, which is likely where he's
going to end up.
Now, in contrast to Richard Nixon, Richard
Nixon had not been impeached.
Richard Nixon resigned to avoid impeachment
after he lost the support of the Republican
Party.
Republicans went to Richard Nixon and said,
it's over.
We will have to convict you in an impeachment
if you don't resign.
And Nixon resigned.
Contrast that which with what happened with
Trump.
Trump has been impeached twice and Republicans
have basically stayed with Trump.
OK, Mitt Romney on one count in the first
impeachment voted to convict.
So far, we don't know when the second impeachment
trial of Trump will be.
But so far, 10 Republican members of the House
voted to impeach Trump last week.
But the vast majority of Republican voters
are still with Donald Trump.
With Nixon, there was actually a reason to
say, listen, Republicans came together with
Democrats.
They all went to Nixon and they said, you've
got to go.
We will impeach.
If you don't go, there is at least more of
an arguable defense of pardoning Nixon.
The Trump fiasco is the opposite.
Trump has refused to even consider that he
did anything wrong, never mind resignation.
Republicans stood by Trump during impeachment.
No one, despite obvious signs that Trump must
go, and he was descending further and further
into the authoritarianism that we saw around
the November twenty election.
So by pardoning Trump, you are in effect also
excusing the behavior of the Republican Party
in standing by him and in spreading disinformation.
So the situation is drastically different.
And then lastly.
Although Trump in the Republican Party.
Claimed to be the party of law and order there
not we saw Trump scofflaw nature his entire
presidency.
We saw the January 6th Trump riots.
We know that they are the furthest thing from
the party of law and order.
For Joe Biden to pardon Trump would be to
effectively say you are now immune from lawbreaking.
Joe Biden should be the president of law and
order, which means he can't pardon Donald
Trump.
But on the other hand, it should be Joe Biden
will not be involved in any Trump investigation.
Joe Biden should simply say to his Justice
Department, to whoever, I will have nothing
to do with investigations into the former
president.
I won't ask you to investigate.
And I will not ask you not to work through
the evidence, work through allegations and
do what you need to do.
That's law and order.
What Trump has done is not law and order now,
is there any reason to think Joe Biden plans
to pardon Donald Trump?
There is not.
Joe Biden has previously said he would not
pardon Trump.
We know lately more and more people have been
saying Biden should pardon Trump.
But hopefully, as far as we know right now,
Joe Biden has not changed his mind on that.
And I hope that he does not.
If you disagree with me, let me know.
I want to hear from you